Yeah.
Now music itself,
uh,
I mean the first musical,
first I'd have to give you an experience
that I had that allowed me to see and
to all of us,
I had already been fascinated
by the gods inside of us.
I concluded at the age of 12 that I was
an atheist and if there were no gods and
they have an above us and know
God's in the ground beneath us,
where were the gods?
Will,
my parents were trying to drive,
dragged me an atheist off the high
holiday services and they were so intent
about it,
but I was literally holding onto the
doorframe of their blue Fraser or by now
forgotten car.
And,
and they were shredding my socks.
They were quite frankly
tearing my shoes off.
They were doing everything they
could to get me up to the temple.
And so I realized in that moment,
if the gods are not above with the gods,
are not below,
where are they?
They're inside my parents.
If they're inside my parents,
they're inside of me
there inside of all of us.
So my task at,
uh,
basically the age of 12 to 13 became use
your scientific tools to find the gods
inside of us.
Okay.
Well you also,
again,
you elaborated on that part of the
story that also made you a tune to those
ecstatic experiences because the
case that you've just laid out,
or I suppose we laid out together to some
degree is that perhaps it was that the
fact that you are isolated as a kid
made you even more sensitive to the
collective belonging element of music
because you were so starved for it and so,
and then the idea of the gods within
that you just laid out seems to me to be
very much akin to what you described as
either your tactic or your philosophy
with regards to PR for
the rock personalities.
Because what you said you were doing
was trying to make them reveal some of
these archetipal figures
within and that that would,
and that you were actually
trying to foster that,
which meant in some sense
you weren't doing PR at all.
Like,
I don't know what the hell you'd call it.
I call it secular shame.
On us.
I was a name I was never comfortable
with because it's so unscientific,
but that was the closest I can come to it.
It's like dowsing for the human soul.
Well,
it would have been a good
name for a PR company.
A second.
Yeah.
But I,
I think that's a very,
well,
I think that's a very useful way of
thinking about it because obviously one of
the hold overs from the shamanic
traditions is obviously music.
I mean,
that's just,
that's just a continuation
of the same tradition.